[GOOGLE LOGO PLAYING]
DANI HIGGINS: Hi.
Welcome to Mental
Health Myths and Facts.
I'm Dani Higgins.
I am a licensed
practicing counselor
in the Denver, Colorado area.
And I am going to be presenting
on basically some myths
and facts of mental
health and also
[? the meat of the video ?]
is actually
going to be more on finding
a therapist and what
to expect from those initial
therapy sessions, as well.
And we'll kind of sprinkle
the myths and facts throughout
and then also have you guys all
come up with some exercises--
participate in some
exercises, as well.
Just some thought exercises.
Don't worry-- I won't make
you get up and move around.
So a brief overview of what
we're going to be covering--
we're going to be
defining mental health
and mental illness.
We're going to explore our
beliefs around mental health
and mental illness.
Explore some common mental
health facts and myths.
Explore some of our
beliefs around therapy
and some common therapeutic
myths and corresponding facts,
and finding a therapist,
the first therapy session,
and then a few questions.
So just a brief
introduction to what's next.
And we're just going to
hold a lot of the questions
to the end, because going back
and forth between the screens
is something I'm not
too super adept at yet.
So we'll just hold
that till then.
So defining mental
health and illness--
mental health involves
effective functioning
in daily activities,
which result
in productive activities--
so work, school, caregiving,
healthy relationships,
the ability
to adapt to change and
cope with adversity.
And mental illness is
kind of any impairment
in that, so any
difficulty in functioning,
any difficulty with your
productive activities,
anything that creates challenges
in your healthy relationships,
so makes it hard to have
healthy relationships,
things that impact your ability
to adapt to change and to cope
with adversity.
So it's collectively to all
diagnosable mental disorders.
And it's health conditions
involving significant changes
in thinking, emotion, or
behavior, distress or problems
functioning in social,
work, or family activities.
And that's the definition given
by the American Psychiatric
Association, American
Psychiatric Association.
So a lot of people
think, like, oh, you
look through the DSM, the
Diagnostic and Statistical
Manual, the manual
of mental illness,
essentially, that
therapists use.
And they see, like,
doesn't everyone
have some of these or
a whole bunch of these?
And the joke is that
undergraduate psychology
students diagnose
themselves with half the DSM
when they take their
abnormal psych class.
But the difference is, is
it impairing your ability
to function?
Is it causing you
significant distress?
Is it making it
significantly difficult
to work or go to school or
maintain your social life
and have healthy relationships?
Those are really the key
factors to make something
actually a illness rather
than just a quirk or an area
where maybe you have a
little bit of difference
from someone else.
So beliefs about mental health--
a lot of people have a
lot of different ones.
We're going to be talking
about myths and facts.
So we're going to want to
explore some of the beliefs
that you might have.
And so what comes to mind
when you think mental health?
And I'll just get that, for now,
from the people in the room,
if anyone feels like sharing.
AUDIENCE: Mental illness
feels like something's
wrong with you.
DANI HIGGINS: Something's
wrong with you, yeah.
AUDIENCE: If you could make
sure to repeat what people say
[INAUDIBLE].
DANI HIGGINS: Thank you.
So mental illness feels like
something's wrong with you,
yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DANI HIGGINS: So stereotypes
about being broken or being
crazy, feeling of that--
that again, that
something wrong,
but in a even stigmatized sense.
Yeah?
What about mental health?
Is there any ideas that
come up about helpfulness
or help being mentally healthy?
What would that look like?
AUDIENCE: Coping with stress?
DANI HIGGINS: Coping with
stress, yeah, definitely--
kind of your
resilience, your ability
to handle the changes
that life throws at you.
So I say write.
You can just think in your
head, if you don't have anything
to write with, or jot
it down in a phone.
But just consider a list
of adjectives, traits,
or other words, when you imagine
someone with mental health
challenges, like, the things
that immediately come to mind.
Some of this is
going to be things
that you've heard society
say or that you've
heard your family say or that
you've heard from other people.
Some of these are things
maybe you actually believe.
And maybe some of them are
good things or bad things
or challenging things
or whatever else.
Just kind of consider--
you don't have
to share this with me at all.
It's just an illustration
for yourself.
I'll give you a few
moments to do that.
OK.
So one myth is that people
with mental health issues
just need to get over it.
This is a really common one, the
idea that you should just pull
yourself up by your bootstraps.
You should just be
able to deal with it,
if you're having
struggles or challenges.
That maybe it's just that you
have a weakness of character
or you just need to
buck up or get stronger.
And that's a really
common perspective
in a lot of society.
Obviously, it's a myth.
Obviously, I'm biased as
a mental health counselor.
But really, mental
health issues come
from a huge variety of factors.
So a lot of times you might
hear about neurochemistry.
And everyone's kind of
seen the Zoloft commercial
with the little bouncing
ball that is sad
and talks about how it
doesn't have enough serotonin.
So there's the factor of
the chemicals in your brain
that are imbalanced,
not hitting--
not going from one part of the
brain to the other correctly.
Maybe there's too much of
it, whichever else that is.
Biology, neurochemistry,
past traumas,
insufficient or ineffective
coping strategies,
the environment
you're in-- so being
in a highly
stressful environment
can exacerbate or even create
mental health challenges.
And trying to just get over it--
well, one thing a lot
of people don't just
go to therapy as
their first go to.
A lot of times, they
spent years trying
to do something
different or trying
to deal with it on their
own or finding ways
that they don't have to
admit they have challenges
to deal with or that they're
not different from anyone else.
And so a lot of people
just try to get over it,
because they've internalized
all these messages.
It involves denying that
you're having struggles.
It involves suppressing
the issues you do have.
It involves a lot of shame,
because, well, I should just
be able to get over it.
So why am I still
dealing with this?
And any time you hear that
should word or should not--
that's usually shame coming
in and judging and saying,
well, you should do this.
You shouldn't do that.
But obviously, that's
not what reality is
and not where you're at.
So that just makes it worse,
and you just feel crappier.
And 75% to 80% of people
who get professional help
for mental health
challenges show benefit.
So obviously, getting
help does something.
So why do you need
to do it on your own
if there is the ability to
get help that will actually
be effective?
Another myth-- mental illness
makes people unpredictable
and possibly dangerous.
So this is kind
of a big narrative
right now, right,
with all the shootings
that are going on in the US.
People are, like, oh, well, we
have a mental health problem.
We have a mental
illness problem.
When honestly, people with
mental health conditions
are statistically more likely
to be victims of violence
than perpetrators of violence.
So actually, there was a study
that I did include in here
somewhere-- hang on one moment.
Yeah, so a study--
a violence risk assessment
study with a sample size
of 1,136 people--
found that the
prevalence of violence
among those with a major
mental disorder who did
not abuse substances
was indistinguishable
from their non-substance
abusing neighborhood
controls, who did not have
a major mental disorder.
So if you did not have
substance abuse issues,
but you had a major
mental disorder,
then your rate of violence
was equal to the people
in a similar environment
who also are not
abusing substances.
Substance abuse doubles
the rate on both ends
for both people with
major mental disorder,
diagnosed major mental disorders
and people who have not been.
But the main risk
factors for violence
are being young, male,
single, or of lower
socioeconomic status--
not mental illness.
Then mental health
problems don't
affect me or people I know.
This is, in large part, because
mental health is not something
that is often talked about.
It's getting talked about
more as time goes on.
But there's still a lot
of stigma around it,
and it's still something a lot
of people keep pretty private.
But someone in
your life probably
does have a mental
illness of some kind.
And in a 2014 study, about
one in five American adults
experienced a
mental health issue.
One in 10 young
people experienced
a period of major depression.
One in 25 Americans live
with a serious mental illness
like schizophrenia, bipolar
disorder, or major depression.
And suicide is the
tenth leading cause
of death in the United States.
So it's relatively common.
It's reasonably serious.
It's something that not talking
about is not helpful for.
Before I move on
is there any myths
that people have heard
of around mental health
or mental illness?
Any things that come to mind
that maybe you don't believe
but you've heard from
people around you
that I haven't covered?
All right.
And I am sorry for
the people remote--
I just-- I will
cover the ones you
brought up, if you
did, at the end.
So another bit of
a thought exercise.
This is [INAUDIBLE] your
beliefs around therapy.
Can anyone tell me
what psychotherapy is?
Anyone have a definition
at all or any idea?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Talking through
mental-related things
with another person?
DANI HIGGINS: Yeah, talking
through mental-related things
with another person, for sure.
That's definitely an aspect.
Anyone else?
All right.
And who goes to therapy?
Or what sort of
person needs therapy?
You don't have to
necessarily share this one.
But you can just
think about that.
What comes to mind immediately?
AUDIENCE: Everyone?
DANI HIGGINS: I mean,
that would be my answer.
But again, I'm biased.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Oh, great.
DANI HIGGINS: OK.
Great.
He said, everyone, by the way.
And then think of a list
of words, descriptors,
or adjectives or
traits that come
to mind when you think about
therapy and the people who
might go to therapy.
And we'll just have a moment
of reflecting on that,
rather than writing it down.
OK.
So this is kind of an official
definition of psychotherapy,
specifically of counseling.
There are a bunch of different
counseling and psychotherapy
and psychology
organizations out there.
The big ones are the American
Psychology Association,
which is--
if you've ever had to
write in APA style,
then that's where
that comes from.
There's the American Psychiatry
Association for psychiatrists
who prescribe medication.
There's the American
Counseling Association,
which is the association
I'm a member of.
And there are a
number of others,
basically for every subset
of counseling or modality
there's probably an association.
But this one comes from
the American Counseling
Association.
They had a lengthy--
31 counseling
organizations came together
or sent their
delegates, and came up
with a unified
definition of counseling
across these different
organizations.
So counseling is a
professional relationship
that empowers diverse
individuals, families,
and groups to accomplish mental
health, wellness, education,
and career goals.
Counselors work with
clients and strategies
to overcome obstacles
and personal challenges
that they are facing.
So it's a wide
variety of things.
It might not just be you're
having some mental health
challenges, or you're
struggling with depression,
or you're dealing with
a crisis in your family.
It might be you're working on
your education or career goals,
and you're kind of
struggling around there.
Maybe there's some
motivation challenges.
Or you want to learn how to have
more effective relationships,
and you're working with that.
So it's a huge
variety of things that
can be covered in counseling.
But-- yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] a
definition category to describe
a career-- like, a life coach?
How would you
compare [INAUDIBLE]??
DANI HIGGINS: That is
a good question, yes.
So life coach and counselors
are very closely related.
And we have to be very careful
from a legal standpoint
to differentiate the two.
Counselors can cover the role
of coaches easily enough.
Coaches cannot cover the
role of counselors or else
they're operating
outside their area.
A coach is more like a mentor,
kind of an accountability
partner.
They are there to help
you do goal formation.
Usually it's, maybe,
career-related, sometimes
a little bit of shape
of your life related.
But not dealing with heavy
emotional stuff, not looking
into your family of origin.
It's a little more problems
it's a lot more problem solving
and kind of advice and
exploration of your goals
oriented, specifically.
Which is still a
subset of counseling,
but is the subset that coaches
are allowed to work within.
Coaches are not currently
regulated as a profession.
They do have certifying
organizations,
but do not have to
be certified in order
to advertise as life coach.
And a lot of counselors do
retire to become life coaches.
That has been the thing.
They just have to be
very careful to not
operate as in the
counseling domain,
and it's a very fuzzy line.
So my understanding
is that there's
movement towards
regulating life coaching.
So that might be a little
more clear in the future.
But right now it's a
pretty fuzzy situation.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
DANI HIGGINS: So
myths about therapy--
therapy is only for people
going through a crisis.
As sorry, what is your name?
AUDIENCE: Sam.
DANI HIGGINS: As Sam
suggested, anyone
can benefit from therapy.
I say almost,
because I hate to use
any blanket terms
that incorporate
the entirety of the population.
But almost everyone can
benefit from therapy.
And it's easier to
develop crisis skills
and stress management skills
when you're in a better place.
When you're in the
midst of crisis
and huge amounts of stress,
it's actually really hard
to learn how to cope
with the stress.
Because you're trying--
you're in survival mode.
You don't have a lot of mental
and emotional or physical
resources to learn
new things and develop
new ways of being that are
different from how you've
coped with things
for your whole life.
That's actually very hard.
And so going when you're
doing a little better
can actually be very
beneficial, so prepare you
and give you better
resilience to cope
with the stresses of life.
So at a previous agency
I worked at called
[INAUDIBLE] Counseling
Center down in Denver,
they divided clients
into level one,
level two, level three as part
of our charting administrative
stuff, and as part of, like,
coordinating care for clients.
And level 1 means that
you are in crisis.
You are having an
extreme difficulty
maintaining your work and
school and relationships.
This is you're having a lot
of impairment in your ability
to function.
And so level 1 is,
like, a lot of people
go to therapy at level
1, because that's
when you're kind of desperate.
Level 2 is kind of the mid tier.
You're having some challenges.
You're having some trouble
in your work and school
and relationships.
You're getting by.
You're kind of able to
keep your head above water.
It's hard, and you could
use some extra help.
And you'd like it
to not be so hard.
And maybe you dip in
and out of level one
when you're a level 2.
And then level 3 is
you're doing really well,
but you'd like to be happier.
You'd like to be more fulfilled.
Maybe you are considering
what do I actually
want to do with my life.
Like, maybe I'm considering
a career change.
Or I'm looking for a
self-actualization.
I'm clarifying my values.
I'm exploring my spirituality.
I'm just wanting to
go in for a checkup,
like a physical doctor.
And so maybe I'm
doing really great,
but I'm going to
come in and check
in every month or
every other month
to just go over things and
have some time to reflect
on how my life is going.
So level 3 is kind of the
everyone else category,
who people don't typically
necessarily think
of as needing therapy.
So another myth is that a
therapist will give advice,
solve problems, and will fix me.
I actually ran into
this the other day.
And someone said, well,
therapists just give advice.
I was, like, actually, I joked
that the first entire year
of my graduate program was
learning to not give advice
and to stop solving
problems for people.
Because it's about helping you
figure things out for yourself
and providing some tools
and providing some structure
and providing some education.
But not telling you what to do.
That disempowers you.
That is not actually as helpful
as helping you figure it out
and giving you the tools to
figure it out for yourself.
So therapists are more like
guides on a backpacking trip,
instead of drivers on a lift.
You have to do the
walking yourself.
They've been there
before, maybe.
But they're not going
to be able to walk
the steps of the
backpacking trip for you
or carry your backpack
for you, because they've
got their own to carry, right?
A car mechanic on the phone,
when your car is broken down
in a remote location
and you can't quite
get it to the mechanic.
So-- and maybe no one
can even get out to you,
but you can manage
to reach someone.
So they can walk you through
getting your car up and running
well enough.
And over time,
maybe you'll learn
how to just fix it yourself.
And therapists are people
who hold up a mirror
so you can better
see and understand
what you're going through.
It can be really hard to
understand your own problem
when it's just you
inside your head.
Someone is having a
bit of perspective
or having someone
reflect back to you
what they see is going on and
what they hear you saying.
And connecting the dots of what
you've described in your past
and what you're
describing now, it
can highlight in that reflection
and bring some clarity
to your situation and help
you figure out what to do next
or where to go next.
Therapists are
just paid friends.
Why can't I just
talk to my friend?
I get the same benefit, right?
I mean if you have a
therapist friend, maybe.
But hopefully not-- hopefully,
your therapist friend
has better boundaries than that.
So therapists are highly trained
facilitators of the growth
and change process.
It's a under-graduate four year
program, a master's program
of usually three years,
sometimes a doctorate on top
of that.
Plus, you can't get
license until you've
had two years of supervised
clinical experience
after grad school.
There's a lot of training.
And then you have to
keep going to trainings
to keep your license up.
Some things that a
therapist provides
that a friend might not--
some distance from
your situation,
physical and emotional,
distance from your life
and social circles.
If you're talking to a
friend about something that's
going on, especially
if you're having
a conflict with another friend
or a conflict with your partner
or challenges there, your
friend might take sides.
Your friend might get
emotionally invested.
Your friend might feel
defensive or concerned
in a way that isn't
helpful to you.
Or is helpful, but
in a different way
than a therapist can provide.
There's more-- maybe
you feel like you
have to protect your friend
or take care of your friends
feelings, any
feelings they might
have in response to what
you're sharing with them.
You have to worry about
how they know someone
or what their relationship is
to all the people in your life.
A therapist provides
confidentiality and neutrality.
So again, that
neutral point where
you don't have to worry about
them necessarily taking sides.
Or they're going to be having
your back, pretty unilaterally.
Because they don't know
these other people.
And confidentiality--
maybe you do trust
your friend to keep
your stuff confidential.
But do you necessarily--
your friend isn't under a
legal and ethical mandate
to keep everything you
share with them completely
inviolate and secret.
A therapist has a strong
mandate around confidentiality,
which we'll get to
in more detail later.
But that, plus the
distance, means
you can pretty well trust
that it's not getting back
to your other friends.
Skillful reflective listening,
psychoeducation, coping skills,
and resources--
so back to that amount of
training therapists go through.
Reflective listening is a skill.
Listening without
judgment is a skill.
Not projecting their own stuff
onto you is definitely a skill.
Being able to educate you
about some of the things
you're going through--
put names to some of them,
provide models that have
been well-studied or formed,
so that you can go, oh,
OK, this does make sense.
I do see how this fits into
my life or the path that might
I might take to get through it.
And coping strategies--
some skillful friends
might have coping strategies
for you, and that's great, too.
But therapists
most definitely do.
Coping strategies being
different skills, methods,
and life changes you
can do to make it easier
to cope with life
and difficulties.
An resources--
they might probably
have community resources and
are able to connect you up
to different areas of your city
or your town that will provide
professional assistance, housing
assistance in some cases,
doctors, whatever kind of fully
rounded area that you need.
So if you get to this
point and you decide,
I would like to
find a therapist.
Or maybe you had a
therapist, and then
you've kind of stepped away
from a therapist for a while,
and you're like, OK,
I'd like to go back.
Or you're really not happy
with your current therapist--
all of which are possibilities.
Or maybe you have a
child or a teenager
who you feel would benefit
from seeing a therapist,
or you want to go see
a therapist for couples
counseling or
relationship counseling--
finding a therapist can be
a really challenging step.
First of all, coming to the
idea that you need a therapist
is a big challenge.
And then, how do
you even find one?
So the first go to is,
if you have insurance,
your insurance
company has a list
of providers on their website.
Sometimes they have an
employee assistance program,
which I believe Google has.
And that is one route
you can go through.
And that will bring up
a list of therapists.
It can be a little
hard to navigate.
Maybe you call the insurance
company or maybe you
go to their website
or maybe you log in.
But that's one starting place.
One note is that the insurance
company's list of providers
is sometimes a little out
of date, weirdly enough.
I find actually that Psychology
Today's therapist directory,
because each therapist
maintains their own profile,
is usually more up to
date as to what insurance
the therapist takes than
necessarily the insurance
company.
Because it can sometimes
take a little bit to update.
I've run into that
a couple of times.
So my go to is Psychology
Today's therapist directory.
And if you do just, like, a
Google search or something,
oftentimes that is just
what it'll lead you to,
some Psychology Today profiles.
You can also ask a
friend or get a referral
from your primary care
physician, your doctor,
anything like that.
And when you're going and doing
your search for a therapist,
trying to figure out what
kind of help you need
is also a big part of it.
Because there's a lot
of different options.
So do you need individual
mental health counseling?
So it's just you and your head
and what's going on for you,
and so you just want to
see someone one on one.
You're probably going to look
up a licensed professional
counselor, an LPC.
You might look up a
psychologist, a PsyD,
but they tend to be a little
more specialized on assessment.
If you're looking for
relationship or family
counseling, you look up an
LMFT, a licensed marriage
and family therapist.
If you're looking
for medication,
sometimes you can just
go to your doctor.
If you're just starting
out, and you're just
looking for, say, medication
for your depression,
your doctor might just
be able to prescribe
you some stuff starting out.
If it gets more
complicated or the things
your doctor's prescribing
you just aren't working out,
then you want to see
this specialist who
is your psychiatrist or a
psychiatric nurse practitioner.
Social services-- if you
need help with housing,
work assistance,
disability assistance,
a disability advocate--
anything in the
social services realm,
then an LCSW, a licensed
clinical social worker,
is who you go to.
Addictions counseling--
you're dealing
with drug or alcohol addiction.
Talk to a LAC, a licensed
addictions counselor,
or a CAC2 or CAC3--
which is a certified addictions
counselor, level two or three.
A CAC1, not so much--
that's more someone who
doesn't have as much training
and maybe runs groups or helps
out or volunteers.
And treatment centers are
also great for certain levels
of addictions issues.
A support group-- that's usually
good in addition to therapy,
but sometimes it can
really help to talk
to people who are going
through similar things
and kind of work
their stuff together.
If you're having difficulty
getting any progress
in your individual
therapy, and you've
been to a bunch of
different therapists,
maybe try a support group.
Learning disability-- like if
you're dealing with learning
disability or
anything like that--
specialists, often
psychologists, sometimes social
workers, but someone who
lists that as a specialty.
There are a whole bunch
of different types
of psychologists, like
educational psychologists,
and so on and so forth.
So some of them have specialties
in learning disabilities.
And if you're looking
for assessment,
you're looking to
get a diagnosis,
go to a psychologist
or a psychiatrist,
occasionally a social worker.
But psychologists are your
go to for assessments.
So that's what all
those strange letters.
There will be more,
but starting out.
So speaking of
psychiatrists, one myth
is that people with
mental health issues
just need to find
the right medication.
And that's not entirely wrong.
Medication can help a lot,
but it's not a complete cure.
We've done study after
study after study.
The studies, of course,
have been focused most
on antidepressants.
So I can't speak entirely
to bipolar, schizophrenia,
and the like, which are also
very helpful with medication.
But for antidepressant
medication,
combining psychotherapy
and antidepressants
is clinically significantly
more effective than medication
alone.
And they found that works-- that
applies to major depression,
panic disorders--
so panic attacks--
and obsessive compulsive
disorder, OCD.
Another one, going the
opposite direction,
is that psychotropics, psych
meds turn people into zombies
and kill their creativity.
So when it's accurately
prescribed and appropriately
taken, it can help people
be more fully themselves,
increase their quality
of life, and have
the capacity for greater
creative expression.
But finding the
right medication,
the right dosage is challenging.
If you're on the
wrong medication,
it can turn you into a zombie.
That's not a good side effect.
If that's the side
effect you're getting,
you talk to your doctor
and say, hey, this
is not working for me.
We need to change something.
If it is killing
your creativity,
then yeah, talk to
your doctor and say,
hey, this is not working for me.
This is not a tolerable
side effect for me.
A lot of people, though,
if you're really depressed,
you might have
creativity, but you
don't have the
energy to do anything
with it or the motivation.
If you have ADHD, you
don't have the focus
to channel your creativity
anywhere half the time,
or the ability to
manage your time enough
to be able to give yourself
the resources for it.
Once you're
appropriately treated,
sometimes it can actually
expand your ability
to use that creativity
and do something with it.
So there's definitely--
this is definitely
a very personal decision.
But I like to quell
the fear that it's
going to automatically
turn you into a zombie
and change your
whole personality
and kill your creativity.
Because if it's the right
med, it's just not accurate.
But the journey to get
there can be changing
a bunch of medications
and that can
be stressful and challenging
and create some changes
in the meantime, so
risk-benefit analysis there.
So Psychology Today-- if you
go to PsychologyToday.com,
then you'll get this screen.
Obviously, not today-- that
was from yesterday, I think.
But then you have this find
a therapist window down here.
And the find a therapist window
lets you plug in your location.
And there's also a
dropdown menu there
that allows you to look up
support groups or psychiatrists
and treatment centers.
So you can also look up
those by your location, too.
So I searched for
Boulder, Colorado,
since that's where
we're at right now.
And it brings up
your list, right?
It can be a huge list, and
that's a lot to sort through.
And those letters we
talked about, LMFT--
so that's your licensed
marriage and family
therapist, LPC, a CAC3.
We talked a little
bit about those.
Those are showing up there.
But also more letters,
clusters of letters that we
didn't cover.
It gets confusing.
In this case, EMDR is eye
movement desensitization--
I don't remember
the full acronym.
But it's a body-based
therapy that's
used frequently for
post-traumatic stress disorder.
DVT is dialectical
behavior therapy,
which is an offshoot of
cognitive behavior therapy
that's very focused on--
that basically combines
cognitive behavior therapy,
which is very
thoughts and behavior
changes, with mindfulness, which
is being in the present moment
and being aware of what
you're doing in each moment.
But if you see on the
right side of the screen--
yes, the right side
of the screen--
you have your various filters,
which helps you narrow things
down very quickly.
And so that's where
we're going to start.
So first you select
your insurance or not.
Maybe you don't actually
want to select insurance.
There's a whole lot of
reasons you might not.
There are a lot of very
qualified therapists
who don't take insurance because
getting on insurance panels
is a chore and a half.
It's a huge amount of paperwork.
And then billing for
insurance is also
an additional large
amount of paperwork,
and then getting
reimbursed by insurance
is a lot of difficulty.
And so a lot of
therapists, especially
people who are in their private
practice, and it's just them,
and they don't have
any assistants,
will choose not
to take insurance.
Some therapists
also don't take it
because they have
ethical qualms with--
because a lot of insurance,
in order to cover,
requires you diagnose.
And some therapists do
not like diagnosing.
And you have to have the right
diagnosis for the insurance
to be willing to
cover it for longer
than four to six sessions.
So a lot of reasons
you might not want it.
You might not want to have a
diagnosis, in which case, you
would probably need
to pay out-of-pocket.
So in addition to
that, there's issues,
which are the things you're
going to therapy for--
more on those in a little bit.
Those top two are probably
the most important ones
to select for.
The rest of it is a little more
based on what your needs are.
So sexuality is if you
need a therapist who's
competent with gay, lesbian,
bisexual, or otherwise
queer clients.
The only options listed are
gay, lesbian, or bisexual,
but selecting one of those.
There's gender, so some people
will prefer a female therapist.
Some will prefer
a male therapist.
You can sort it by gender
so that it only shows
you male or female therapists.
Language-- if you
need your therapist
to speak a language other than
English, there's a whole list.
Faith-- sometimes
therapists advertise
their religion or
the religion they
specialize in working with.
There's a whole list there, too.
Types of therapy-- this
takes a little more knowledge
about what you're looking
for and what kind of therapy
is out there.
But if you have a
preference, maybe someone's
recommended that you go
get EMDR for your trauma.
Or maybe you would prefer to
get cognitive behavior therapy.
But there's also stuff out
there like art therapy and dance
movement therapy.
And maybe that's more
your style and sounds
more appealing to you.
But there's also online therapy.
Some therapists offer
video counseling.
Generally, video counseling
is somewhat less effective
than in person, because
there's less information
for the therapist to go on.
But there can be reasons
that you might see--
you might go for
video counseling only.
So there's a whole bunch
of reasons for counseling,
as we were talking
about earlier.
And the list of issues on
the Psychology Today website
is pretty comprehensive.
I mean, it doesn't have
everything, everything.
But it has quite a lot.
So maybe you're having a
chronic relapse issue, or anger
management, learning
disabilities, pregnancy,
prenatal or
postpartum depression,
needing some
medication management,
or grief, or infidelity, or
suicidal ideation, depression,
impulsivity, career counseling--
there's a whole bunch of things
that you might be
going to therapy for.
And then selecting a therapist--
so you've got this huge list.
And now what?
Again, a whole list of letters--
we've gone over a
number of those.
The only one I think I
haven't defined in there
is NCC, which is a
National Counsel--
certified counselor.
And that means that they
have passed the NCE, which
is the National Counseling
Exam, which they
had to do if they're in Colorado
to get their license practicing
counselor, anyway.
So a lot of LPCs
will also be in NCCs.
Registered psychotherapists,
LPCCs and LSWs--
LSWSs-- so a registered
psychotherapist
is a Colorado only thing.
A couple of other
states have something
similar or comparative.
But if you're a registered
psychotherapist,
it means you are not licensed.
It does not necessarily
mean that you
have a master's
degree or a supervisor
or much training at all.
In the state of
Colorado, all it means
is that you've taken
the jurisprudence exam
to pass a very legalese
exam on the legality
around counseling and
your ethical requirements,
and you've gotten the department
of regulatory agencies
to sign off and give
you a license number.
So a registered psychotherapist
might not necessarily
be unqualified.
I mean a lot of times, interns--
so people who haven't
graduated grad school yet
and are interning somewhere
under a supervisor--
might be registered
psychotherapist.
It's kind of a CYA
on the legal end.
LPCCs are people who have their
master's degree in counseling
and have passed their exam,
their national counseling exam.
But have not done
the full two years
and gotten the
full 2,000 hours of
supervised clinical experience
to get their full licensure.
So they're postgraduate,
pre-licensure
So they're usually
under supervision.
And for other people,
looking remote,
who are not in Colorado,
these letters and stuff
varies by state.
So for instance, in Ohio, an
LPC is the pre-licensure version
and the LLPC is the
fully licensed version,
just to be confusing.
But in Colorado, it's
LPC is post-licensure.
LPCC is pre-licensure.
LSW is a pre-licensed,
postgraduate social worker.
LCSW is a post-licensure
social worker.
Confusing enough?
So things to keep
in mind when you're
looking through a
therapist's profile
is, do you like what they say
on their profile or website?
Does it appeal to you?
Does their tone appeal to you?
Do they seem fluffier than
you'd like or more intellectual
than you'd like?
Do they meet your needs?
Do they work with the issues
that you're looking for?
Do they work within your
budget or insurance?
Do they work for your location?
The number of people I've
had message me and ask me
if I can work with their child,
when I list that I only work
with adults is pretty high.
So check those things before you
message a potential therapist
so you're not wasting your time.
So here's an example
of a therapist profile.
I'm using mine,
because that's easy.
So as you can see, we've got
my name, picture, credentials,
summary, a link to my
website, my office address,
a number to reach me
at, a way to email me.
Under that specialty
section on the left side,
therapists are allowed to
list up to three specialties.
And that's basically
their top three issues
that they specialize in working
with or prefer to work with
or have the most
experience working with.
And then issues continues on.
I just wasn't able to fit
them all on the screenshot
of the slide.
So that's the first half.
You also see that up in
the upper left hand corner,
it says verified by
Psychology Today.
That means they've checked
your license number to see
that you are actually licensed.
And in the second half, it
shows my qualifications,
years in practice.
A note on that--
sometimes you might want--
there's advantages to a
therapist with less experience.
And there's advantages
to a therapist
with a lot of experience.
Therapists with a
lot of experience
obviously have more
years on their belts.
They have worked with more
people and more different kinds
of people.
Therapists who have
fewer years of practice
often have more up to date,
more recent information,
are a little more flexible.
So there's little
advantages either way.
If you have a lot of alternative
lifestyle or minority
identities that are
not as well-defined
and/or well-known in
older generations,
then seeing a younger
therapist can be a good go to.
If you are concerned
that you might
be too much for a
therapist or that they
might be overwhelmed by you
or not know how to handle you,
going to a more experienced
therapist is not a bad idea.
So this also has that
I work with adults.
I work with LGBT clients.
It shows the modality.
I work with individuals.
I don't do couples and
family at this time.
So if you were looking
for couples counseling,
you'd go somewhere else.
It also has what I
[INAUDIBLE],, what I charge,
and what payment methods I take,
any insurance plans I take,
which is currently none.
I hope to change that, but like
I said, a lot of paper work.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is there any
unique way to interpret
the average cost per session?
DANI HIGGINS: So
the average cost
per session, how
to interpret it?
AUDIENCE: I guess the
question is [INAUDIBLE]..
DANI HIGGINS: How what?
AUDIENCE: How low is it?
Like, how much information
is really-- is it
a case by case
[? random thing? ?]
DANI HIGGINS: So assume that
the highest part of the average
cost--
so in this case the
$80 to $120-- the $120
would be the therapist's
standard cost.
$80 would be how low they
will sometimes flux or flex,
based on your ability to pay.
And their reasons for that
or the criteria for that
would be variable per
therapist, so you'd have
to ask in the consultation.
And then types of
therapy is something
that you don't even
necessarily need
to worry about too
much right away
because unless you
know a lot about what
different types of
therapy you'd like
or what kind works for you or
you think might work for you.
Because what's most
important is, actually,
the relationship between
you and the therapist,
which we'll get to in a
little bit in more detail.
So the first step is you
email or leave a voicemail
with your name, phone number,
email address, and briefly
what you're looking
for help with.
And I say leave a voicemail
because most therapists
are probably not going
to pick up the phone.
It's pretty standard
practice for them
to just let calls
go to voice mail.
Because you don't want to be
available 24/7 immediately
to all your clients.
That can lead to some
unhealthy dependencies or you
as a therapist not taking care
of yourself and burning out.
So it's pretty
standard procedure.
So if you are calling
a bunch of therapists
and no one's picking up the
phone, that's probably why.
But they should contact you
within the next 24 hours,
by the next business day.
And then most therapists
offer a free consultation,
either on the
phone or in person.
And this is a
chance to interview
your potential therapist.
You're essentially
looking for a--
it's a relationship.
It's a professional
relationship,
but the relationship aspect of
it is the most important part.
How will you click?
That's hard to find
and hard to figure out
who you click with, right?
You don't click
with every friend
every potential friend you meet
or every potential partner.
So this can be some
trial and error.
And you also want to know,
are they actually going
to be a good fit for you?
Some therapists offer
a free initial session,
but I haven't actually
seen that in years.
So I don't know if people
actually do that anymore.
AUDIENCE: They [? do. ?]
DANI HIGGINS: OK.
Yeah.
OK.
So we have someone who
has experienced that
or know someone who's done that.
So things you might
ask are what's
your experience with the issue
I'm coming to see you for?
What's your experience
with my demographic?
Like, maybe, I'm a trans person.
What's your
experience with that?
So you might also ask how would
you work with someone like me
or someone in my situation?
Get a little bit of a feel for
what their approach might be.
Have you been in
therapy, or do you
get consultation
and supervision?
This is-- maybe feels a little
challenging to ask a therapist.
And I understand if you don't.
But I really recommend it,
because it's a really bad sign
if your therapist has not
had therapy themselves.
They need to be able to have
that awareness of themselves
in order to provide
therapy to other people.
And anything else you might
be concerned or curious about.
So certain
therapeutic approaches
are more effective than others.
This is efficacy of different
treatment approaches
is hard to study, and
it's highly debatable.
The best we can figure is
that some treatment approaches
are better for certain
disorders than others.
But even then, it's a very
minor significance in efficacy
from the studies we've done.
What we do across so
many different studies
at this point--
the link I have down
there is to a meta
analysis of all of those--
is that the quality of the
therapeutic relationship
is the primary
predictor of change.
And mind you, quality
of the relationship
doesn't mean that you
never have difficulties
or that you never have
conflict or that it's just
really easy and stress-free.
Because actually, we've
found that if there's
been a rupture, like
a conflict, and then
a successful repair
of that conflict, that
has led to a more healthy,
more change-inducing,
high quality relationship than
if there is no conflict ever
or if there's a conflict
that wasn't resolved.
So the most important
thing here is,
when you're interviewing
a therapist,
your potential therapist, do
you feel like you could maybe
grow to trust them?
Do you feel like they're
someone you could talk to?
So do you feel like
this is someone
you could click with or
have a relationship with,
a therapeutic professional,
talking about some
of your deep feelings with?
And then, one is if I
talk about something
illegal, or some past abuse
that I've experienced,
my therapist will talk to
the police or hospitalize me?
A little tricky--
legally and ethically,
we're bound by HIPPA, which
is the Health Information
Portability and Privacy Act and
confidentiality restrictions.
But there are some
confidentiality exceptions,
things that therapists are
mandated or required to report.
If you are an immediate
threat to yourself--
so if you are going
to kill yourself.
You have a plan.
You have the means.
You're going to do
it after you leave.
They're going to have to
call the police on you.
But if you just say, I'm
thinking about killing myself.
That's not immediately you're
going to be hospitalized.
That's going to
be-- the therapist
is going to go, OK, we're
going to do a suicide risk
assessment now.
And they'll go
over some questions
and try to build a safety plan.
They don't want to call the
police on you, trust me.
That's not a good
feeling for anyone.
So if there's any possible
way we can be safe,
get you to be safe without
that, that'd be great.
Or if you can go to the
hospital of your own volition--
much better.
Danger to others--
if you are going,
I'm going to go
shoot this person,
and I'm going to do it after
I leave here with this gun
that I have in my car.
They're going to call
the police on you.
Again, this is going to
be a talk it through.
And try to evaluate if
you're an immediate threat.
Or a danger to space
others might be in--
I'm going to go
blow the building.
That's going to-- we're going to
have to call the police on you
again.
If there's child abuse or
neglect happening right now,
like, if you were
abused as a child
and it's not likely that your
abuser has access to children
now, then that's not
a mandatory report.
If you know a child is
being abused right now,
and you have given the
therapist the address
or location or names, then
they have to report that.
And ideally, they'll walk
you through reporting
it yourself or you two
can report it together.
But they're required
to report if there's
child abuse or neglect when
they have enough knowledge
for identification--
same with at-risk
elder abuse or neglect.
So if your spouse or your
doctor called the therapist
and asked anything
about you, they
have to say I can
neither confirm nor deny
that that person is
seeing therapy here.
Unless you have filled out a
release of information form
for that person, which
specifies what they can share.
Court orders will sometimes also
be a confidentiality exception,
if there is a significant
court order for the therapist
to release their notes.
And I'm going to speed
through this as fast as I can,
because I'm running
short on time here.
So your first session,
you get orientation.
They'll tell you, like,
did you get here OK?
Here is where the bathroom is.
Here's who I am.
There's probably
intake paperwork
that you might have filled
out before the session that
develops the therapist's
policies and procedures
and probably lets
you give a history.
And there's the getting
to know you phase, which
is one to three
sessions sometimes,
where they get your
history, do any assessments.
So on a scale of
one to five, rate
this thing for the past
two weeks, sort of thing.
And figuring out your
goals for therapy together.
What do you want out of therapy?
There's an idea that therapy
takes years or takes four
to six sessions, which is--
before the Affordable
Care Act, insurance
would cover four to six sessions
and that was usually about it,
with flex, based on need.
But the length of therapy varies
per person and their needs.
For about 50% of clients,
it takes 15 to 20 sessions
to be pretty much better.
And a lot of people like to
go 20 to 30 sessions over six
months to really feel like
symptoms are fully in remission
and got a handle on it
and it's stabilized.
And 12 to 18 month
duration or longer
for some co-occurring
conditions or chronic problems.
I specialized in
trauma, in PTSD.
So a lot of my clients, I
see for six months to a year
and sometimes a little longer--
is my usual with clients.
But shorter is
definitely possible.
And how do you get the
most out of therapy?
Honesty versus
dishonesty-- therapists
aren't actually mind readers.
They don't actually teach
us that in grad school.
So if you're not
honest, then they
have to take you at face
value a lot of times.
It's not fun for anyone
and it's not productive
for me to try to figure out
when you're telling truth,
when you're not.
It works much better if
I'm just believing you.
And so I tell
people straight up.
I'm just going to believe you.
It's no great feat
to deceive me.
Because I'm just going to
choose to believe what you say,
what you share with me.
And I will call you out if
there is inconsistencies,
because maybe there's some
self-deception going on.
But I'm going to believe
what you say to me
and believe that you're going
to be honest, because there's
no point in this otherwise.
Openness versus closedness--
actually sharing stuff
rather than holding stuff
back or hiding stuff.
Obviously, this takes time.
You want to build trust
first with your therapist.
And this can be hard to learn
how to do, so that takes time,
too.
But efforts towards being open,
rather than just being silent
or holding stuff
way back, will get
you to get more out of therapy.
And willingness
versus willfulness--
being willing to
try stuff out, even
if it's really silly
sounding or feels awkward,
that your therapist suggests.
Versus going, no,
that won't work.
No, that won't work.
No, I'm not going to try that--
you know, shooting
down everything.
You're not going to get a lot
out of it if you don't actually
try.
OK.
We are very close to
time, but I will try
to take a couple of questions.
Oh-- electroconvulsive therapy--
the effectiveness of
electroconvulsive therapy
and myths and facts.
I do not feel I'm
entirely qualified
to talk about that
one, because that's not
something I personally have
studied in great depth.
It definitely used to be
a more common thing that
was considered to be not
as effective in the way it
was used.
But then there's
been developments.
I know that some
people still use it
in a much different
approach than it
used to be used that
might be more therapeutic.
But I am really not sure.
I'm going on very
fuzzy memory here.
This is not my area.
Advice for talking to loved
ones who could possibly
benefit from therapy,
but believe something
along the lines of--
I've been to therapy in the
past and it hasn't helped.
So what's the point?
So going back to that
willingness and openness
about therapy-- therapy doesn't
work if you're not honest
open and willing.
If you're feeling
coerced to go to therapy
or are pressured
to go to therapy,
and you're not engaged
or willing or motivated
for yourself, you're not going
to get as much out of it.
It's going to be a lot harder.
You're going to
spend months getting
to the feeling motivated and
buy in stage before you actually
do the work of therapy.
And that can be
part of the process.
But it's a lot of money to spend
on something you're just not
really willing to
do or invested in
or prepared for at this point.
So I have worked with
someone for a year
who was very ambivalent,
very not entirely motivated.
And it was exhausting for
both of us, I'm pretty sure.
I just felt we were
going around in circles,
and there were times
where I was, like, really?
Are you sure you
want to be here?
If you're not getting
benefit out of this,
you should not be
paying me money,
and I should not be
taking your money.
They're, like, no,
no, no, no, no.
So after about a
year, they finally
left for a month or two,
and then they came back.
And I'm like, OK, so--
you have to buckle
down and work.
Or this needs to end, because
I cannot ethically continue
to see you if you're
not getting benefit.
And, like, no, I'm
really ready this time.
I've had these experiences
over the time I was out,
and I really want to work.
And then they suddenly over
the course of three months
made huge progress.
They went from a
level 1 to level 2.5.
And so when someone's at
that point of readiness
then they can get
a lot of benefit.
If they're just trying to be
convinced by everyone else,
and they're not
willing or ready,
they're not going to
get a lot of benefit.
And there isn't going
to be much of a point.
And getting them there--
sometimes you just have
to be patient and talk
from your own experiences.
Maybe therapy has
helped you a lot
and you can share how it
helped you without telling them
what they should be doing.
Speaking from your
experience can
be one of the more
powerful ways of swaying
someone or influencing someone,
rather than telling them
what they should be doing.
Again, that should
word is more shaming.
Well, thank you.
Appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]